welcome everybody uh thanks so much for
joining me today
my name is brandon minnick and in this
session we'll be talking about building
graphql apis in c sharp
i'm so excited to be with you here today
because
i first learned about graphql just a
couple years ago and i remember the
first time i got to sit in a session
just like this and learn about it
my my mind was blown i was so impressed
by how amazing graphql is and just can't
wait to share that with you today
graphql is a
really amazing technology that i truly
believe this is the future of building
apis so kind of like how today
everything or most things are built in
rest and you know if uh if a fellow
developer came to you and said hey can
you help me build this api
i'm trying to build it and so using xml
you'd be like soap why why are you
building a soap api
i truly believe in a couple years from
now
we'll be saying the same thing about
rest versus graphql so in say five to
ten years somebody will come to you on
your team and say hey can you help me
out i'm working on this rest api
endpoint like rest why why are you doing
it in rest
let's do it in graphql
um because it
is an insanely powerful technology and
what's interesting is
it's already being used by millions of
developers around the world big
companies like netflix uh uber airbnb
github are all already using graphql
but they're doing it all in in
javascript um graphql still hasn't
really
taken a foothold in the c-sharp world
yet uh so
just by joining me today and hanging out
in this session we are literally at the
forefront of this graphql movement in
csharpen.net and truly will be the
leaders on our teams and our communities
helping to get these started
um
because like i said the.net
community hasn't really embraced graphql
yet but
we will so before we get started today i
want to point out two links that you'll
see on the bottom of just about every
slide today
on the bottom left this is my twitter
handle this is the best way to reach me
you can find me on twitter at the code
traveler so if you have any questions if
you want to chat about c sharp stuff
graphql stuff
my messages are always open
i'm actually a mobile developer by trade
i build ios and android apps in c sharp
using xamarin.net maui
and we'll explain more why i love
graphql so much as a client-side
developer in just a bit
and then here on the bottom right
this is my my website and i built a web
page just just for us just for today's
session
so this is where you can find everything
don't so don't worry about memorizing
anything today uh just make sure you
grab this link at some point so
grab it take a picture of your phone
bookmark it you can share it with your
friends your colleagues because this is
where you can find
everything from today's session so
everything from the slides i'll be
posting a link to the recording once
we've got it up on youtube uh the code
we're gonna be doing today i have that
already done in and saved in github so
i've got links to that as well as
graphql workshops and also more
resources on graphql that you can use to
help you get started on your journey
so
what is
graphql um well
in its most basic sense it's a graph
query language uh that's quite literally
what graphql stands for uh but
really what it is is it essentially
inverts how we think of our apis
um so today for example as
as a mobile developer
i rely on rest apis to give me data
and also for me to update things on the
server and so the the back end teams
they've built out a bunch of rest apis
that i could use to say retrieve it
retrieve data about a user so i could
call my user api
and that will always give me back the
same dto that same c-sharp model the
same properties and fields
but
depending on the user i ask for maybe i
input a different user's id i'll get
different information back but that
model is always going to be the same
from that same rest api endpoint
likewise if i want to change anything
server side
there's a specific api for that so with
rest i make a post request or an update
request or whatever it might be
to update something server side
and that cert or that rest api
only does that one thing so if i want to
update a user's email address i'll have
to send a post request to the api that
can do that and if i want to do anything
else
we got to build a whole nother rest api
and usually that's not too bad
especially if i'm working by myself i've
i've got a couple apps in the app store
that i've built both the mobile side and
the back end side for so it's really
easy for me to do that but in reality uh
we work on teams and building a new rest
api endpoint for something we need in
our mobile apps means that well we've
got to open up a ticket with our back
end team
they add it to their backlog eventually
they get around to creating that new api
endpoint in a couple weeks it'll make
its way to
qa and then prod and then finally
i can consume that api and leverage it
in my mobile app
um with graphql
we're flipping that model all the way
around
the way graphql works is from the client
side
i can request anything i want
i basically tell
the graphql endpoint exactly what i want
what i need and it sends it back to me
and so
with graphql there's no wasted data
there's
no wasted round trips back and forth to
the server it's a lot more efficient and
in terms of just
velocity developer velocity right now
now everything's there it's just waiting
for me to ask for it and i don't have to
wait on my back end team to build out
new apis and test them and get them to
the production servers before we can
finally add these features to our mobile
app
so
let's go back
because to really understand graphql
it's helpful to know
where it came from
so
let's go back to the year 2012. it's
crazy to think that was almost a decade
ago
but in 2012 was when facebook
launched their first native mobile app
uh
facebook always had a web app before
then
but in around the 2012 time frame they
said you know what i think this ios and
android thing is is here to stay we
should probably make an app for it and
they did and facebook launched the app
to the app store and it just got slammed
in reviews
tons of one star reviews two star
reviews if anybody here was on facebook
using the mobile app at that time you
probably remember
the facebook app was really slow it took
forever to load
it would burn through your mobile data
plan because it was just pulling in so
much data and then at the same time your
cpu is running full throttle so your
phone's overheating your batteries
draining and that was all the reviews in
the app store
because
the facebook app has a lot of data i
mean what what is facebook without data
right so they kind of needed to do that
and you can look at these screenshots
that i've posted here these are
screenshots from from my facebook page
and just thinking about all this data
that loads just when i launch the app
just when i tap that button on the home
screen i get information about uh let's
see this is the news feed here on the on
the left so i get uh
my news feed updates from my friends
about there's my friend taking his son
to get donuts in the morning and so
there's the picture there's a date
timestamp there's his name his profile
picture uh above that are the facebook
stories so again with their profile
pictures and their usernames and the
videos embedded there
and
what also loads when you launch the app
is the notifications page so even more
data comes in
on this notifications page so
information about
my buddy jeff getting married and um
i've got an event coming up called taco
week and there's even
friends
that i might know facebook you know
wants to keep you on the platform so
they want to connect you with more
people and so here's people i don't even
know that they're saying you might know
this person and here's how many mutual
friends you have in common and all this
data is being downloaded as soon as you
launch the app on your phone
and so it's really no surprise that when
facebook first pushed this mobile app to
the stores the app stores that
it started burning through people's
cellular data plans it started uh really
burning through people's batteries
because the cpus got a process and
display all this information
and when you think about it
from the lens of rest it makes a lot of
sense so what's
what's going to happen when i launch the
app right the the facebook app's going
to first hit one rest api user slash id
so it's going to pull down information
about me
and then once it has that information
then it can go to the next api and pull
down information about my upcoming
events and it can go to another api and
pull information about
my friends and then once it has
the data back from those apis it can
make another api call so for each friend
request it's got to then make a user
request for that person and get their
profile information and their uh and uh
how many friends we have in common and
so what we get with rest apis is this
cascading
api request so you start with one or two
but then you have other api requests
that depend on the data that comes back
and then you might have another api
request to make that depends on the data
that comes back from that so you kind of
get this pyramid shape of api requests
and
this is is really why the facebook app
struggled because each api request means
it's going from my phone to the server
back to my phone that round trip even if
it only takes 10 30 milliseconds
if we have dozens if not hundreds of api
requests that are launching and
depending on each other when the app
opens well those really start to add up
and so the the developers at facebook
were thinking about this and they're
like there's you know there's got to be
a better way
and that's when they came up with the
idea for
graphql
so
quick aside yes i did just say uh
facebook invented graphql um that was
back in 2012 but today
graphql is owned by what's known as the
graphql foundation so a lot of us here
for c-sharp developers might be familiar
with
the.netfoundation.net foundation is a
not-for-profit that helps to
curate sponsor
open-source c-sharp projects
specifically you know popular nuget
packages that we might all use in our
apps that if the developer decided to
stop working on them one day then we'd
all be kind of hosed
the.net foundation supports all those
projects
likewise with the graphql foundation so
the graphql foundation again not for
profit um it controls and iterates on
the graphql spec so graphql is
constantly improving
and they're also the ones that kind of
shepherd and help sustain the graphql
libraries like for all sorts of
different programming languages from
react to c sharp so if you don't like
facebook don't worry
you don't have to rely on them for your
graphql technology anymore because it's
all in the hands of the graphql
foundation
but right so
so the engineers at facebook looked at
that problem they had with making all
these cascading rest api calls pulling
in all this data some of it some of
which they're using some of which
they're throwing away and they said
there's got to be a better way
so they consolidated everything down to
one
graphql api endpoint
now
you might be thinking
wait a minute
this api endpoint has to then return all
the data facebook has an insane amount
of data
they probably have petabytes of data if
not more um so how how do you get all
that data back from one api call and and
even if it's just scoped to the user you
know i've been on facebook for over a
decade that would still be probably
gig's worth of data coming back from
this one api call even it was just
scoped to me
well
the way graphql works
is
we reach out to or when we make that
request to the graphql api
we specify
exactly what we want
so take a look at this example query and
response
on the left
i tell
the facebook api exactly what i want so
i say that i want to get information
about a user so i pass in that user's id
and then i say i want to know that
user's name
and the upcoming events count
and also for that user show me their
show me some friend suggestions uh in
this case just give me one give me the
first one
and for that friend let me know that
person's name
and how many mutual friends we have in
common
and so i send that to the graphql api
endpoint and what comes back is this
json response
now this is the same json that we know
and love it's the same json that we use
in in rest so if you know how to consume
a json payload deserialize it using
either system.tx.json or newtonsoft.json
into c sharp then you already know how
to handle the graphql response which is
just really nice so the learning curve
handling these responses super low
because it's the same thing that we
would get back from a rest api
but look at the data that came back
it's exactly the data that i asked for
there's there's no more data in there
there's no less data
if we look at it it gives me the user
name which is me brandon minik it shows
me that i have four upcoming events
count or four upcoming events
and then for the one front suggestion it
lets me know that hey there's another
guy on facebook his name's seth juarez
and you have 18 mutual friends maybe you
should reach out
so
what we get here
is
one round trip so i don't have to make
multiple api calls to the server i don't
have to
like we had to in rest first hit this
one api endpoint to get information
about me the user and then hit another
api endpoint to get information about
the mutual friends and so we can do this
all in one round trip one payload
and
we're not throwing away any data um with
with rest there's a lot of times we get
the responses back and there might be
10 properties in that dto and we only
really want two of them so what do we do
well we just throw the other eight away
but
with mobile apps that's painful because
i just burned through your data plan
because i have an inefficient rest api
endpoint so with graphql i don't have to
worry about that anymore i get exactly
what i want
back from the server
and if i want to
change the data i get back i can just
modify the query so again i don't have
to wait on
a new api from my back end team i can
just literally change the shape of the
response to handle whatever new feature
i'm working on in my mobile app
now
yes this is
a
json response but if you look closely
this query is not json
it it looks kind of like json um but if
you look a little closer you'll see
there's there's no double quotes
we don't have the field name colon value
um this
this is our query language so this is
this is where the ql in graphql comes in
and
i know what you're thinking like oh
great here he's been telling me how
amazing graphql is but now i gotta learn
a new language for it
i don't have time for that
well don't worry about that it's
actually really easy um and to be honest
i've been using graphql for years and i
haven't memorized the query language so
let me show you what that looks like we
can pull up the
github's graphql api
so what i've done in my browser i've
navigated to
boop
this is github's graphql api so if you
when you navigate to here
in your browser you're create you're
greeted with this page called or this
tool rather called graphical uh it's a
clever play on words because you know
it's it's a graphical user interface for
graphql so graphical
and you just you get this for free when
you build your graphql endpoint your
graphql libraries
will have this graphical user interface
in it
there's a couple of them out there this
one's graphical there's another one
called graphql playground there's
another one called banana cake pop but
you don't you don't have to worry about
building this because it kind of comes
with the package so
um the first thing i want to show off in
graphical because this is one of my
favorite things about graphql
is this docs tab here so when i tap on
the docs tab
we'll see it opens up this documentation
explorer
and this is really cool because graphql
apis
are self-documenting
so the way graphql has to work or does
work is it already knows
all of the all of the objects classes
fields that it can respond to back to
the client
and so these tools like graphical like
graphql playground um
all they do they just walk through that
tree
and they can provide us with all the
documentation for our api so the github
team didn't have to write any docs for
this they don't have i mean they do
they're still you know good developers i
guess
but it's all here in this tool for me
now
the first thing we see here in this
documentation explorer
and i'm going to zoom in on it here
is there's two root types
these are the same two root types that
you'll see in every graphql backend
the first one being query and the second
one being mutation
now a query is essentially a
a read-only request from the server it
means
i want to get data from the server
but i don't want to change any data on
the server so a query you can kind of
think of like a get request right we're
not we're not changing anything on the
backend we're just requesting data back
we're making a query
a mutation
does change something server side so
that would be the equivalent to our our
puts our updates our deletes
and rest and so
because i am i am logged into github
right now this is this is live on my
github account we're going to stick to
queries today
because i don't want to risk changing
anything and breaking any of my projects
and so
what i'm going to start doing here is
building out the graphql query here on
the left and to do it like i said you
don't have to memorize anything because
it tells us what to type so i'm going to
type in this query with a lowercase q
and right away as i start typing it
you'll see intellisense pops up so
that's pretty cool you don't even really
have to know how to spell it i mean i
guess you could copy paste it too
but yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna type in
query
and then what this tells me
is anytime i make a query to the
graphql api it's going to return back
this query type or this query object and
so if i click on this query object
now i can see
all of the different requests that i can
make so these are all the fields that we
can get back from the github api and if
you're familiar with github a lot of
these will probably look familiar like i
can get information about a github
organization i can get information about
a github repository i can get
information about
github user so let's do that let's do
let's query for a user
and again i'm just going to type in
whoops let's go
[Music]
back
accidental click there
so i'm going to do is type in what's
here on the left again
and so here my query i'm going to type
in user
intellisense great looks like i'm typing
everything right
and then it also tells me i have to
specify a login now in in the graphql
spec
i mean
there's there's a couple base types and
you're probably already familiar with
things like date time string
int bool those are all the base types
and graphql and everything builds off of
that but what might look a little funny
is this exclamation point
the the exclamation point means that it
is not nullable so
what what this is telling me here is
that if for my user login i have to pass
in a string i can't just ignore that and
put in null so for
let's bring up that oh
intellisense even finished typing it for
me so for the login i'm going to put
brminic this is my github username um
github calls well get them
call some logins because it is your
login but it's also just my public
github username
login makes it sound like it's something
secret i shouldn't be sharing
but um but right so now what i've said i
want a query
about this user br minik me brandon
minik
and you'll see i'm still not done yet
there's a there's a little red squiggle
here saying that there's a syntax error
because because it expects more data i
can't just say give me
everything you got on this user because
remember graphql only returns back what
we ask for so
if i click on the user object this is
what's going to return from my user
query we can go a layer deeper and see
what fields can i get back about a user
and again if you've used github before
this is probably pretty intuitive that i
can get information about like a user's
bio i mean you can format an html if
maybe you're working on a website that
makes it easier um you can see company
what else do we have created at i guess
that's the time date time i
created my github account
there's things like followers so
we can
tell it exactly what we want
there we go
and then when i click the execute button
there we go there's our json response so
just like we were talking about earlier
we provide a query saying here's exactly
what i want i want to know more about
this user br minic
i want to know their bio what company
they work at uh what else i request
the date it was created at looks like i
created my github account in 2015 and
the total followers account or total
followers count that they have on github
and that's exactly what we got back and
again this is just json and the response
so it's the same json we know and love
we would then deserialize this consume
it in in c sharp
and likewise
let's say i uh
i didn't i didn't care what
what date and time
we created my github account we just
delete that we re-execute this query and
it's magically gone so we get exactly
the data back that we asked for
now
so
again just take a moment to think about
how powerful this is so from the client
side
i can request
anything i want as long as the graphql
server
exposes it as long as it
will send it back to me
i can request that data in any shape i
want i can add more queries here um so
we could add another query here about a
repository and we can get all this
information in one round trip
even though some of the information like
the followers count
that's nested data with rest that would
take us two round trips because i would
have to get information about the user
and then i could
ask for information about followers but
with craftql one round trip and it puts
the power in the hands of the client so
the api team doesn't have to constantly
create more and more rest apis that only
do one thing because now we have a
graphql endpoint that does
everything
okay so this is cool but
how does this really work right because
we're just in the browser we're
literally on github servers so ah like
is this really how we use graphql in our
apps no like we're gonna be
we're gonna be sending http requests and
making uh creating payloads so how do we
do that
so to show that off i'm going to open up
a tool called postman
now
if you've never heard of it postman is
just a great tool that's one of my
favorites that helps us explore and test
out apis so anytime i am building out a
back end i'll use postman to make those
get requests to it post requests to make
sure my api's working like i think it
should before i start writing code
because then at least i know the api is
working and it's my code that's broken
so
here in postman we're going to make a
call to github's graphql api so i've
already punched in the url for github
it's api.github.com
graphql
and
the first thing i'm going to do i'm
going to set this to be
a post request
now you might be thinking
wait a minute
post that's
that's a rest thing we're talking
graphql
well it turns out
every graphql request
is just a post request
so if you already know how to make a
post request in c sharp you already know
how to communicate with a graphql api
endpoint so the same way you would
create a new http client send a post
request to your rest api
it's the same post that we're using for
graphql
this is
this is also something i find funny that
if you just google rest versus graphql
you'll see
all these wars going back and forth and
blog posts like uh rest is dead long
live graphql and i'm like
i don't know if you guys know what
you're talking about because graphql
literally uses rest it's it's built on
top of the rest protocol so rest isn't
going anywhere but
yeah i also agree that graphql is the
future but anyway so we set this to be a
post request
and then
in our body we're going to add one field
so the way graphql works we have one
field called query
and the value of that field
is literally what we just figured out
here so this is this is literally what i
do for my apps i
i jump into
the the gui on the server so graphical
in this case i play around with it until
i get my query shaped the way i want it
to and then i just copy paste this so
i'm going to copy this query
and i'm going to paste it in here
and
let's see i'm going to just get rid of
some of this white space so it stops
yelling at me get it all on one line
one more there and then
we also want to
keep those quotes
there we go so no more red squiggles
and so
and so that's it uh just one field
called query i paste in the value of the
graphql query that i just figured out
using graphical
and then when i send this post request
to the graphql api at github
we get back
again exactly the data i asked for so
again if you already know how to make a
post request
you can already access graphql api
endpoints because it
it quite literally is the same thing
okay so i know i've i've been throwing a
lot of stuff at you so let's do a quick
review
graphql apis have one endpoint so unlike
rest where you have multiple endpoints
that each just do one specific thing
with graphql there's just one endpoint
that does everything
graphql apis are self-documenting so
because when we create our graphql
endpoint you'll see that in just a
minute when we jump into the code to
create our our own graphql api uh we we
have to define everything when we
create our graphql server and so these
tools like graph graphical that we were
just playing around with
that documentation explorer just walks
through the tree and sees all the
queries that i've created
and then just exposes that to you as the
documentation so you don't have to worry
about necessarily keeping your docs up
to date with the api because the docs
are the api
graphql requests are just post requests
so they leverage rest's post http method
so again if you already know how to make
a post request you know how to make a
graphql request
that graphql request
is it contains json in the request body
and that json just contains one field
query
and to which we just copy paste our
graphql query
and then that graphql response is json
so just like rest apis graphql apis also
return the same json that we know and
love
okay
so let's get ready for some code
now
i do want to highlight the two most
popular graphql libraries for us in.net
in c-sharp
um the first one it's
i gave it the crown because it's
currently the king um it has the most
nougat downloads it has the most open
source contributors um yep it's open
source on github it's called graphql
dash there we go.net
now this
this was also the first um so there's a
pretty easy explanation to why it has
the most downloads because it's well
it's been around the longest um it works
really well i i've used it in a couple
of my apps but there's a rising star
here and it's called hot chocolate
there's a there's a company based out of
switzerland called chili cream that
makes hot chocolate they've got a lot of
fun names and you'll see a couple more
later
hot chocolate is incredible this is this
is what we're going to use today for our
demos
like i said it's it still doesn't have
as many nougat downloads
but it's just because
uh graphql.net came first so highly
recommend hot chocolate to you
this is gonna be the one we we punch
into our app today so
let's do it let's jump into some code
here
i've got visual studio for mac opened up
and again
don't worry about memorizing anything
because this demo is already done it's
already up on github and i'll make sure
to share the link with you before we
before we end so sit back and relax
we're just going to make a
an empty asp.net core app
and yeah let's do it in dot net six that
sounds good
we'll call it our graphql demo
no thank you
okay so the first thing we're going to
do we're going to add in that hot
chocolate nougat package
so let's search for hot chocolate
and specifically there's an asp.net core
version or
implementation so let's see did i pass
it hot chocolate dot
asp.net core that's authentication
hot chocolate let's just try and type in
asp net core
there we go that's the one we want so
we'll just add in the hot chocolate dot
asp.net core nougat package uh we'll
give this a second to just to download
and add it in
um
i've noticed this
this is a pretty substantial nougat
package um it's got a lot of
dependencies in it so sometimes it takes
a minute
so tell it while this is working on it
uh what questions do we have so far
about graphql
yes right here in the front
access control um so
similar rules apply for rest um so like
for example the github api they use
bearer tokens
um so i just include that in the header
and i already i did that before the demo
because i didn't want to share with you
guys my actual bearer token but uh yeah
that way it authentic authenticates it
knows it's me and so yeah all that same
security that we know with rest is is
still there
we're still downloading i think i saw a
hand right here yes sir
which um a lot of teams working on
different domains within your
application or application area so how
would you consolidate
different teams working on different
parts of the graph
good question so yeah just to repeat it
uh for everybody at home the question
was what if you have hey there we go
accept those terms because i don't have
a choice um what if we have multiple
teams at our company and we all work on
different parts of the api so it sounds
like maybe you have different sub
domains um one has each has its own rest
api or set of rest apis
so you got a couple choices because you
can still do that with graphql you don't
only have to have one api endpoint
it's easy for me to consume as a user of
say github because i just have to point
to the one but internally does github
have maybe a couple or their own
internal apis
also built on graphql graphql probably
so you can split it up like that you
could have your teams each have their
own different subdomain
and actually we'll see in the demo now
that we've got this installed how
it might get a little messy but you
could still use version control and
merge it all into the same place you'd
probably just have to be
well disciplined in your devops so let's
uh yeah let's keep running with this
demo because
maybe that'll answer your question
so uh first things first
has anybody here played with net six and
these minimal apis yet
okay just a couple hands uh so this
might look a little weird um it was
definitely weird to me when i first
created this template when i was getting
ready for this demo i was like whoa
where's where's my startup where's my
configure services method um
but after playing around with this for a
couple minutes i love it uh because this
this is it this is what this is an
asp.net core app with
where they've
the template at least here has mapped a
get api onto the index that if we ran
this right now just bring up a web page
that says hello world
so
we're going to keep running with this
because i think
as we go you'll pick up kind of where
this might go in the old asp.net core
templates so the first thing we're going
to do we're going to add
graphql to our services
so i just come in here and i say add
graphql server
and then i'm going to chain a method to
it that says add
query type
and
i haven't we haven't created a query yet
so i'm going to actually leave this
empty it'll give me a red squiggle but
hopefully that'll be a good reminder to
come back to it
and
then the next thing we want to do is
we want to add in our graphql endpoint
so to do that we'll say app.use routing
and then we'll say
use endpoints
and the hot chocolate library gives us
this handy dandy
map graphql method
so again
with what i just do
technically two lines of code but
they're on three different lines that's
that's basically it we've set up our
graphql server um this graph this map
graphql method
if we uh cheat a little bit and zoom in
on
intellisense we can get a sense of what
it's doing it's just giving us the slash
graphql endpoint so once we keep
building our our models and build out
this api and launch it in the browser i
just go to slash graphql and that's my
graphql api endpoint
okay so what do we want to build today
well um
the kind of canonical hello world demo
in graphql is kind of a building a
library so so let's create some books so
i'm going to use
i'm going to use records
keep this code nice and concise so i'm
going to say public record
book
and each book has a string title
and we'll say public record
author
and each author will have a name
and also each book is going to have an
author
as well
so these are going to be my two data
types that we're going to be playing
around with and
now we can build out that query
that belongs up here where the red
squiggles are
so i'm going to create a class called
query
and
normally if we were building this
ourselves for our real apps we'd be
pointing to production data right we've
got a database somewhere that we can
point to to pull the data out but
i don't have that i mean i guess we
could i could have set that up ahead of
time but why don't we just make some uh
some dummy data here so we'll just make
a list of books
and
let's make up some books here so let's
create a book called
um
how about i love graphql
and authored by
me
brandon minnick because i love graphql
uh we can create another book
uh we'll say graphql is the future
and
i also said that so let's attribute that
one to me
and then let's create one more book
and let's say let's call this one like i
love
soap
and xml
by this other
author
um let's say his name is probably
john
i hate
new
technology
there we go
what do we miss
oh i see it
comma
parentheses
no more red squiggles all right
okay so that's just gonna be our dummy
data like i said if if we're building
this for real we'll be pointing our
graphql queries to our actual production
data but speaking of those queries what
do they look like well
i'm going to say
i'm going to build one called books so
this one will just return a list of
books and i'm going to call it get books
and not surprisingly we're just going to
point to
our books data
so
this again normally point to maybe our
entity framework
or actually what's really cool is let's
say you have
oh
this is also a great answer for your
question
let's say you already have a lot of
existing rest apis well a lot of
companies nowadays are doing because
let's be honest we put a lot of
investment into our existing backends
right we don't want to just throw them
out and redo them so what you can do you
can actually build a graphql endpoint
that points to the rest apis so
essentially you can put graphql in front
get all the graphql goodies so you know
fewer round trips being able to query
whatever data you want and you can just
point it to maybe you already have a get
books rest api so we could just point to
there and then graphql will use that to
consume the data which is which is
really cool um
okay let's just start with this one
query for now called get books
and i named this class query so let's
put that in here get rid of those red
squiggles
and let's run and see what
happens so if i did everything right
we'll launch the browser we'll see edge
pop up here in a second
great so there's the hello world that
came with the template
but
what i'm going to do is go to slash
graphql
to access our graphql endpoint
and so just like how we were in
graphical earlier i mentioned that
there's a couple of these graphql gui's
banana cake pop is the one that comes
with hot chocolate so when you start
playing around with uh
the these tools from the company called
chili cream they've got a lot of fun
names like hot chocolate is the graphql
server
strawberry shake is the name of their
client side graphql implementation and
then we've got banana cake pop here for
the
graphical user interface
and it'll take a second to spin up
because it's actually trying to
communicate back to a server it because
what you can do with banana banana cake
pop
is you can log into it
meaning basically you can create a
profile save your queries
and so let's give this a second to
keep spinning it'll it'll show up in a
second and then once it's loaded it's
loaded we won't have to do that again
but
come on conference wi-fi
i'll tell you what i know i saw another
hand i think around here when we were
asking questions earlier
we can do another question while we're
waiting for banana cake pop
maybe not
all right can i show the code again oh
yeah of course
so
so again that that graphql server
configuration
we're just adding we're saying add
graphql server to
our service collection
we're adding that query type and you
know what like i named it query it
doesn't have to be named query like i
could have named this
library query um the name kind of just
means nothing it's just the name of our
class that
um hot chocolate's going to use to
consume
and looks like it's taking a while let's
see if i can
if i go in private if that'll clear some
cash
maybe i'll leave it both up and we'll
have we'll have a little race here
maybe
we'll try it in safari
i love it
oh there it is okay in private look at
that
nice and quick okay
so we can get rid of safari no thank you
all right so once this loads we just
connect it to this graphql endpoint
hopefully that'll turn green it does
this is one of my favorite things with
banana cake pop and it's so silly but i
love it if you hover your mouse over the
chili cream logo
he says hello
so anyways back to the graphql goodness
so
right in the code we created a library
query
and we've only had we've only created
one query so far so this is one that's
going to return our books so if i start
typing in query we get that intellisense
just like we expect
and look at that there's our books query
and
let's see okay great there it is if we
zoom in here
this tells us that the book's query
returns
a list of books so the way this graphql
nomenclature
works is
the the square brackets tell us that
it's a list so it's a list of type book
and then again the exclamation point
means it's not nullable so this is
there's two exclamation points here one
on the outside of the list says the list
will never be nullable so at worst i'll
get an empty list back
and then inside of that list will be
books that are also not nullable so i'll
never get a null book back and so
just like you just like you probably
guess we can query for books
and inside the books there's our our
title that we created so the title is a
string which is also not nullable
and also we can get the author and get
the author's name
and just like you expect when we click
run
we get our json response back
so
in just a couple lines of code
we've stood up a graphql server
and if we again if we already have
existing data points or rest apis we
could just point our graphql
uh graphql queries to those rest apis
and
really quickly we can have a graphql
endpoint that we can use
because again the cool thing with
graphql is like ah maybe i don't care
about the title of the books i just want
to know the authors
we can get that back
now
one of the cool things i like about uh
hot chocolate
is
the reason it knows that nothing was
nullable
is because
it uses c-sharp nullability uh so if you
remember in c-sharp
eight c sharp nine what are we on now
this is ten
so recently in c sharp uh they came out
with nullable where we could say
book
might be null so if i if i update my
data set here to say book
is now nullable
that gives me the opportunity to pass in
a null value
and if i were to rebuild this
and run it again
and so here i just need to reconnect to
the graphql api and if i type in my
query
now if i zoom in on book
book no longer has the exclamation point
because a book could be null so the list
still can't be null because i didn't
make the list nullable but just by using
nulla nullable in c sharp
hot chocolate automatically translates
that to us so
if we ask for the list of books again
author name there we go we should see
one at the end
no so pretty cool
now
what we can do we can we can expand on
this a little bit
we've got some time so
what if we wanted to just
get back one book so let's say we want
to get
one book back
we'll call that get book
and to do that that means
somebody's got to give us
something so let's let's filter by the
title so to get a title from our books
back we'll say books dot
we'll say first or default since maybe
they give us a title that doesn't exist
and we'll just compare the
books
title
to the title they gave us
and we'll bring that down
so we can all see it there we go
and so again
rerun this
and once that's running
just reconnect to my graphql server
come back up create a new query
look at our intellisense and there it is
so now we have a book type so we can
just we can call that book query and
just like we expect that book requires a
title so in here i would say title
i love
graphql
and then again we can't just get all the
data back from the book because graphql
wants us to specify the fields that we
want so
i'll say yep i want to know even though
i gave the title you can tell me the
title again
and then we'll run it
and we get our book back
so
um
let's see
why don't we do
one more
just for fun because we can also do
something on the authors now even though
we don't have
and we'll say an author's database we
have a books database
we're just using c sharp right so we can
just take advantage of the fact that
this is this is link so we can get
books
and
let's see yeah that author should
probably be null just in case they give
us one back
and we'll we'll filter out that so
wherever the books whoops
the books author
whoop
we want to know
they got to give us the author's name
though um so the author name equals name
bring that on one line again
and then we'll say
if it exists give me the first one if
not
that's okay
and what that's nullable
getting red squiggles book to author oh
because i got to select
author now
so get a nice nasty beautiful link query
that's yellow because that's nullable
too
we'll rerun that
and
there we go reconnect to the graphql api
maybe
maybe not
oh it crashed on me huh what did i do
wrong get author
do do do
do
wonder if my cert expired
fatal error debugging needs to be
terminated
i'll just build the same code again
that's a
that's the best way to do it right
oh there it is
it's already in use
it's in use because you crashed on me
now
anyways um so let's see
actually let's see if it is
if it's actually in use because we could
actually open up postman
uh just like we were doing earlier with
the github api
make a post request
in that body put in
some json
boop and say query
query
let's say books
title
let's see if this works
no it really did crash on me well dang
um so
i did want to end with uh one more
little cool trick here in postman um
let's see since
our our server crashed on us let's jump
back to
the this github example we were looking
at earlier
because there's something cool that
postman's also added uh this was not
around when i first learned how to use
graphql but there's actually this
graphql button here
and so instead of putting in our
raw json and having to remember like uh
what was that syntax again that field's
called query and then i paste the query
but do i still that include query um
what you can do you can click this
graphql option here in postman
and
i'm just going to cheat i'm going to go
back to the github explorer and copy
paste
and so i can just copy in that raw
graphql query into postman
click send
and there we go we get that same data
back
so
if you haven't gotten a chance yet uh
this is where you can find everything
that we covered today so make sure to
grab a picture of this with your phone
bookmark it you can share it with your
colleague share with your friends that
couldn't be here today
help them to get up to speed on graphql
because this is where you can find the
slides i'll be posting a link to the
recording once ndc's got it up the
the open source demo that we just did
i've already got that saved in github
and linked on the website here for you
as well along with let's see
uh chili cream has a hot chocolate
workshop i've got a link to that there
as well as links to the chili cream docs
links to more about rest versus graphql
and just a lot of helpful resources that
were really good and helpful to me when
i was learning graphql so
hopefully they'll be helpful for you as
well
thank you
okay so we do have about five minutes
left um
happy to answer questions you're also
welcome to hit the road if you want but
i'll be here also be floating around the
conference for the rest of the day too
if anyone if anybody wants to chat so uh
yeah
what questions do you have about what we
chat about here in graphql
yes
the database you own yourself in your
own database or also data which you
fetch from
web services
oh good question so the question was
does it make sense to use graphql for
your database or if you're fetching data
from other web providers does that also
make sense
i'll say
yes mostly
assuming those other web providers don't
have latency concerns or uh rate
limiting throttling concerns uh
especially if you own them so kind of
like we were talking about earlier a lot
of companies
that they'll just keep their existing
rest apis and then they'll just build
graphql on top of that and graphql will
just so for their books they probably
already had a
book api for the library and so they're
just pointing to that
and then that already knows how to get
the books um so yeah you can absolutely
use it for web services but yeah just
keep in mind
it's it's not gonna be a magic wand so
if those web services have like
throttling rate limiting or they go down
all the time then
that's just gonna trickle back up
through your graphql
endpoint uh good question though uh what
other questions yes uh
are there a way to know which fields
from the database are actually prepared
from the graph
great question
so
the question was
how
or is there a way that we can specify
which fields are exposed from the
database because yeah we don't want to
be exposing passwords or any sensitive
user information so
oh i'm sorry
if i'm to query a database or let's say
10 fields but the model data model has
is there a way to limit what's actually
retreat from the database based on the
query
if you ask for books name only
it doesn't make sense to load all the
other fields from the database
right um so good question i'm not sure
if hot chocolate has any of that
optimization built into it and again
just to repeat that question i was like
what if i only want to know the name or
the title of the book but in the
database we've got everything about you
know the author the year was written the
copyright information but we don't care
about all that so could we just
make it so the database query itself
only returns back the title um
i know there's a way to do it i'm not
sure if we manually have to specify that
like if maybe we do a link query that is
more unique to that or if there's a
generic way of doing it
but i know it is doable because i know
that's also one of the
big benefits of graphql so uh a common
question i'll get is
well we're already using odata so why
should i switch to graphql because oh
data filters the data right
um and it's like
yeah i mean kinda like that's one
feature of graphql that odata is similar
with but um but yeah with odata
it's still gonna make that full database
query
it just filters the data that leaves and
comes back
so you don't get the performance gains
and i know with graphql
you can
but do i know how to do it off top of my
head i don't
so
good question but definitely something
to look into and yeah i'm actually
interested maybe hot chocolate has a way
to do that built in because like i said
it is
it is the best
i mean hot chocolate by the way is also
part of the graphql foundation so just
like we were talking about earlier with
his foundations and not-for-profits and
making sure these libraries stick around
because they're a member of the graphql
or because they're a member of the.net
foundation you can feel safe and secure
knowing that if you use hot chocolate
for your apis that
it's not going anywhere um they're not
pulling the plug on anytime soon
um
is that one minute left okay cool yeah
we do have one minute left i think i saw
one more hand
we could also chat afterwards
that works too all right well thanks
again everybody and hopefully i'll see
you around the rest of the day
[Applause]
you